[Music]
hello folks
today is a good day for a hunt I think
Ben I agree it turns out I and I didn't
know this cuz this wasn't really planned
I was like hey Ben surprised what are
you doing at 11 a.m. cuz I heard we
could play this game that has us hunting
some monsters which we're still doing
tomorrow it's gonna be you and John Luke
I think we're gonna do later game stuff
tomorrow
you're like high ranked hunts yeah high
ranked hunts like you're like 60 70
hours in I mean here I can kind of show
the tease I guess we're not gonna show
the character just in case because I
don't want to spoil our more I don't
want to spoil anything that's exactly
I'm 71 hours in right now so and we have
so basically it's like a review copy but
we're gonna take you guys to kind of
like the first hour or so maybe we'll go
a little longer than that character
creations whatnot I guess we can watch
the cutscene I guess that's what happens
here yeah if I remember right okay we're
about to find out it kicks off yeah
damn you loading screen that wheel right
there it looks a lot like this you have
these legs which is also out we're
streaming see at these later today at
2:00 p.m. but for now Monster Hunter and
thank you guys all for tuning in as I
did not think it was going to take this
long I am on like a default ps4 I don't
have a ps4 oh yeah so which is gonna be
a thing as people are probably gonna ask
yeah we are not just normal ps4 right
now but just because well that's what we
gave Ben if you're curious how it's
gonna run on an OG PlayStation 4 we got
yeah boom just fight already
oh don't worry Angelo we'll get there
we'll get there but we got to make a
character first yeah exactly
sisters and brothers of the
it's time I'll keep my farewell brief
never was much with words once you board
this ship there's no turning back the
next ground your feet will touch will be
that of the New World
if any of you have lost your nerve and
step away now isolator no I lost my
nerve
very well then sales safe and strong and
made the Sapphire star light your way
you can watch while doing that get
together it's true take the phone in
with you yeah have a seat relax we have
it early lacell because we have a review
copy essentially yeah which there's a
bunch of people that are streaming ready
with preview copies and whatnot so this
is just a really weird thing but there's
a lot of cutscene there are the there
are characters with voices and they act
and I don't catch that make food and
bring you food but that's that's been
like and but having it look like that
like I want to eat that ham right now
yeah right oh man kind of recent books
this poor lady just wants to sit here
and read her books
[Music]
believe you me I get it
anything could happen to us like a celeb
top to you oh [ __ ] oh what's mine well
what's my name and what do I look like
turns out we're gonna find out gonna
make a character right here boom alright
where you going with some boy girls the
female cuz I'm a lady
that's bear ok you can start off with
some it's that's your way more in depth
than the beta oh yeah where I had 6
heads to pick from but uh you get the
you get those yeah beginning characters
you can kind of pick and go with or you
can get detailed here until fans change
your face a bit are you gonna make a
normal person a list celebrity or
sometimes as other shows of the beamed
monsters you know I'm not that great at
it
so I can't I can't make like a celebrity
yeah alright well we'll kind of go
through the options a bit and kind of
just poke around and see what there is a
really cool thing actually is that
hairstyles for both males and females
can be put on either like so nice okay
it's like these are the the dude
haircuts sweet okay still available for
you to be a little mohawk ass kind of
nice yeah
little lucky I Jane actions samurai
ponytail kind of going on I think I'm
gonna go with some short hair shorter
hair it seems like okay good choice
okay you want to be safe when you you
head in yeah you don't want that pulling
on your hair exactly fighting monsters
mmm-hmm change your eyebrows a bit
here's a question and I guess think
about your answer okay yeah how so how
much of the stuff down the road or how
in terms of armor how much do you feel
like you would actually see your face
not very often there is a good chunk of
maybe like a couple hours where I didn't
see my
okay so like I'm just wondering how much
I should personally invest into my
characters face if I I'd see knowing me
I'll probably be covering it up like
destiny like I'll just always have a
helmet on but it's it's it's it's
definitely worth putting some thought in
your cage because it when it does show
up you're like oh my god yeah I will say
though that the one interesting thing is
the armor sets do look different on male
versus female yes and uh I can't I don't
think I can talk about the specific
armor but I'll just say that there's an
armor that Ben had on that I was like oh
[ __ ] that looks just dope and then that
was on your male character and then I
went to like John Luke or Justin's desk
and they had they're like oh yeah I got
that armor set too and I'm like oh that
doesn't look that looks the same it
looks like they're there are similar
like accents and notes but in terms of
like the overall like aesthetic of it
there was like something you know that I
was just like oh looks better on the
male that's it's very personal mm oh he
wears a black penis whoa they kind of
change stuff up
yeah but wow it didn't have that wow
you're pretty much kind of looking the
same okay yeah all right but I'm saying
like there's like pretty drastic yeah
yeah like there's a pretty drastic
difference like I'll just I won't go
into too much detail but basically even
doing Oh sick there you go yeah yeah
it also trips me out that you can do one
eye the one I think that's like like oh
there's a you know ff10 yeah yeah yeah
yeah but yeah like the guy had a
straight on like full-on like mask mask
where it was like an animal like or it
reminded me like an animal
but then that the females version didn't
even have the full mask and it was more
like a like it just covered the mouth
almost or something we're like part of
the like it went along her jawline and I
was like oh that looks very different
like that's my only two choices you can
do some scratches if you feel like mm
that might alter my might decision on
which sex I want to make for the hunter
I'm gonna eventually make which is
gonna be on Thursday sadly for me
basically well I I'm in the same boat as
everyone else in this chat probably I
can't I haven't really played the game
outside the beta but I'm definitely
looking forward to it
seems like a pretty meaty game there's
right up my alley too a lot to it you
sure you ever go for the deep hiss
before he stops impossible you know I
will all right
whoa all right well we got the cam out
of one that's that okay put that on
there I guess just do like oh it's kind
of like faint but it's there
oh all right wow she got some all right
yeah it's like she painted her face to
go out for the for hunt tonight yeah
we're building a character exactly you
can preview some expressions if you want
away see what they look like well they
do stuff because that's very important
Oh what was that this is I didn't know
this is kind of reminded me of like the
Duke can you come like the when you
would or not do come from sorry
Wolfenstein where you could change the
slider yeah and then it would do the
different facial expressions sorry I had
a lot we were talking a lot dude Newcomb
yesterday during that stupid heads up
game that was playing with Joey it's
understandable
you only have four different people how
much does this matter by not at all we
not very much testing almost always you
can you can customize the color if you
want I'm guessing there's no advantage
to like being in like no armor right
like Dark Souls were like you would I
mean you'll take more damage other than
yeah that's that's a bad it's challenge
oh we can pitch these down too
this is this is a weird part of the
procreation oh I got to turn this out
huh
there's 20 voice types it's really
important you know
[Music]
maybe I'm wrong
like okay this I don't want to spend too
much to get we should we should all
write leather yeah all right here we go
what's your name bill - I'm just gonna
be luck do my usual thing or just
Merrill the best was last week when no I
I was like I'm pretty sure that's been
and then and then John Luke the whole
time was just like nah man that's not
Ben Ben's fill I'm like I think I'm
pretty sure that's been like who else
would pick Meryl all right font and then
he's like oh oh yeah you're right it was
that's cool you can do the cat to you
this is the most important pallet go
we're gonna crank up that fir crank it
up to the max get that oh yeah it's
looking real good yeah real good
let's keep the calico color I think
that's
you can change the pattern he's a tiger
Justin called his it's I'm so stupid
right now I can't remember it it's this
it's the the cat that likes a little
alarm yeah Pleasant Garfield Garfield
yeah I called his calico Garfield it's
or at least Garth
I mean called him Garth I mean to this
cat customization I kind of wish there
was a dog pet but it's all good we get
the armor on it's like all about the
armor so I guess it doesn't matter so
I'm very upset
used to be able to get like the who he's
mad so there's will see him in a bit but
the chef cat just like he's missing an
eye on the tree and you used to be able
to give your cat like a missing eye and
I was really you can also do one eye
color oh yeah the dark color I'm sure
change your ears around a bit Ben needs
to be closer to his mic all right you
know what you don't talk louder over
here right in it I feel like I never get
complaints because I'm not just talking
with you're just you're you've been
doing this no I think I just talk really
loud
dang I'm going to fail again that broken
tail because I feel like that gives me a
good character that's that's what about
the nub now do late we're we're in there
moved on we're past the matching clothes
here for our cat lair yes as hyzer
Gregor said for the people that are
trying to decide well which platform to
play I think that the the best choice
would be to pick whichever one you you
know the most people are playing on yeah
because monster hunter is definitely a
game you could solo your way through the
whole whole way but it's definitely I
feel like even more fun when you have
yeah you people to play with either much
more it's a game you've got to play with
people just but there is quick like a
matchmaking
there's matchmaking but it's much more
fun when you can blame your friends for
taking all your carts instead of a
random person all right what's his name
oh wow god no I'm into it you start
yelling and there's a crew all right
let's do it let's all right now that
we've do some hunts spend 15 minutes
making a character which is what you
have to do if you're gonna invest into a
vehicle in the long haul you don't want
to have any regrets gonna be looking at
this character for a long time you've
got to make sure as anyone that's
playing an MMO knows I'm still
regretting what Rob did to my destiny
character I still have him he looks like
he-man slash Luke Skywalker it's it's
not a good it's a real rough time yeah I
always have my helmet on
this dream will decide if I buy it or
not woo big pressure from Aragon Aragon
frost here yeah I hope I want more
people to play this game man I was gonna
have been experiment with weapons but if
we need to sell you on it then I got to
have him swag at some point like I feel
like I don't know I was very lukewarm
also because Dragonball Fighters is
coming out the same day yeah but I
ultimately decided that I'm gonna go
walk this path I think because we're
Dragonball yeah it's just hard for me to
spend because I know if I if I do
Dragonball Fighters I'm gonna have to
invest a lot of lab time true but I feel
like the loot reward that I'm gonna get
out of this is gonna make me want to
just keep playing I guess I don't I
don't know like after watching like bet
like the the above average or maybe
average to above average players playing
Monster Hunter
I got a deeper appreciation of just like
what you can do in combat that I was
like oh that's really cool I think I
want to do that and I think that I have
at least a good enough knowledge with
Dragonball fighters where I can still
compete whereas this is something like
freshen you like this like I don't know
this every year I feel like I have one
game that I'm like oh I think this is
the one to get me into it yeah and this
this is the Monster Hunter game that's
gonna get me into Monster Hunter I guess
I feel like this is gonna be the Monster
Hunter game that gets a lot of people
into it which is a very good thing yeah
it's cuz it's for a long time launch
honours always had a huge barrier to
aintry life
and look at the game you see people
playing that looks like it's a lot
mm-hmm
I don't know if I want to like jump into
that but this one is really it's got a
really good set up to kind of get new
people yeah
headset audio is gonna go with
dragonballs totally a viable choice I
think both are I think awesome yeah so
you can't go wrong either way our review
will be out tomorrow so stay tuned for
that for Monster Hunter our review in
progress for Dragon Ball is out we're
about to show gameplay ing we just had
to make that character get through that
cutscene there's a process you just
don't jump right in anymore
now it's a cinematic experience exactly
you got to take it all in as it happens
you might know this question better than
I would
I'm guessing you need ps+ to play with
friends yeah I mean it's a pretty safe
bet I would think if you missed it we
were on a ship we got attacked I'm
literally running around on the back of
the monster right now handler it's on
there yeah up in the sky we're
definitely not gonna get that ship down
if that's what you're hoping I mean look
there's two solid games coming out this
this Friday I kind of wish they weren't
coming out on the same day I probably
would have already played both but you
know hey it's fine more options for
people to play dry that game looks great
this game looks also a lot of fun
in my opinion at least probably embeds -
yeah but uh I'm getting I was gonna buy
this really thankful that I was able to
get like my time in Monster Hunter and
kind of like probably spare the time
question yes
are you able to change voice pack like
is there like the option to go Japanese
oh yes there is a monster hunter
language which you can probably switch
to us okay Rox so I could in theory you
know after it maybe this part or
whatever go to options and select
Japanese as a language with subtitles
then yeah okay because that is my
preferred choice if you're digging about
Dragon Ball fighters I would say
probably do that too
I've never been a huge fan of English
dub I hate that I'm probably gonna go
English on my Dragon Ball really yeah I
also I'm not a very big Dragon Ball
person I'd like know nothing about it
what was that one dramatic cutscene I
think in English he says [ __ ] to Frieza
instead of you fool I think you fool
sounds much more in twins
well you fool is I think like actually
like what he says Oh in the anime I
think someone's gonna probably tell me
I'm wrong but I'm pretty sure that's
right there's always someone who knows
which is the great part about life come
we're a tattoo this is the full game we
have a review copy and we're able to
stream certain parts of the game like
pretty much early on
it's like roughly the first 15 hours or
so we're only gonna do about an hour
though yeah everything we can stream
opposite direction feels
that has like the horn that comes out
the horn the wing and slings to fly
around shoots fire out look at that boy
he's real gross nice yeah
saved we did it
good thing these pterodactyls were here
someone was mentioning have you noticed
any like off like the lip-sync being off
at all we're not really I haven't played
in a I haven't noticed it also for like
I said earlier a good part of my time
was spent with a helmet over my
character's ah I get fair okay yeah
that's probably what's gonna happen to
me so whatever handler okay nice
Andrew moon has helped verify that you
guys say you cool there you go so how
would you explain Monster Hunter to
someone I'll give my take then you give
yours alright go oh uh it's it's
basically to me hunt and loot and eat
eat / craft so you eat / craft what you
need then you go on the hunt to kill a
monster then you scavenge his his his or
hers body - then make sweeter loot / or
sweeter gear pretty much that's what I
would say to someone that's pretty solid
oh it's basically taking what you said
and almost changing kind of but yeah
it's it's about prep and building
yourself up doing research on a monster
because you can you track things down as
you like actually
oh the weak points are here and you can
knock off this part of them to get like
this part yeah I will say the game yeah
is pretty cool in the sense that it's I
think it's pretty approachable but then
it can also get really like in-depth and
there's a lot of like different tactics
like as I said as I watched more you
know above average or maybe veteran type
players playing I was like oh like in
that beta they were using like that
almost like ironclad
chili or whatever the thing that you
would use to cloak but then there's like
a like a metal version of that oh yeah
the poncho yeah and like that helps like
not get you staggered you still take
damage like that helps you like kind of
stay up and keep attacking and like if I
had known that I would have told John
leave to do that when we were fighting
the New Yorker gansan yeah right but it
turns out that's like that's a thing you
could do so you know but I mean like
even after like we did that stream -
like I was I was fighting it because I
wanted retribution and I figured out
that like it's susceptible to poison
damage so stacking poison damage
probably would've been a good thing and
it's weak points are specifically like
its head and its tail and its front legs
wow they actually block a lot of stuff
off here just used to that well you're
safe and I think the beta lets you walk
past there - at least I know where I
gotta go I'm just gonna walk there and
I'm like wait a minute this is all there
guiding me through it drifting wolf zero
says Monster Hunter is a game that
splits between an RPG where every quest
is a boss battle and simple farming at
fetch quest in between to get you ready
for more boss battles yeah you kill
monsters to make pants and then you come
back and kill more monsters to make
better pants about that pant life that's
my monster hunter briefing so if you
like the pants grind get you a monster
hunter
so so I'm gonna brought a good point up
in terms of like levels and like how
would I
I guess you differentiate from the
bosses and I know that in some cases
like I was watching by uh like later
game boss down the road like yesterday
and you're like yeah I don't think I
should be fighting this guy so I'm
assuming the game kind of just checks
you by how much like damage you get take
or done to you versus like how much you
do to them in a way I guess is that kind
of how do you its that yes it's off of a
gear and obviously you you become better
as a player as you play more - okay
which works out but yeah if if you have
higher level gear you'll take less
damage you also once you get into harp
like higher rank stuff you'll get like
skills and resistances and stuff like
that that you can actually have gear
sets for like oh I'm gonna fight this
monster now I'm going to stack fire
resistance and the other cool thing
eventually when we do get to selecting a
weapon because people are starting to
talk about weapons one will kind of put
out a vote into the chat to see what you
guys want to see and then we'll probably
try to do his best to showcase that but
the thing is you get to pick from any of
the 14 to start right or basically you
have every weapon right let's start we
give you a starting weapon for each type
so you could kind of pick and feel
around and if if it is your first game I
definitely recommend going into the
training area and just messing around
with weapons and seeing what you kind of
like there's a training area in the base
game the same as the one in the beta or
is it I haven't okay that's fair because
like I was doing the one in the beta and
I just found it interesting that the
things I was locking on to were barrels
I was like ah like I just want to hit
something else other than these barrels
this is not a like helping me visualize
my target you know whatever it's fine I
like the fact that you can go into that
kind of like training area with you know
those different types of weapons to
really try to figure out which one you
like and some are definitely more
complicated than others so it gives you
a good way to kind of feel out what what
you would potentially like to be like
I'm pretty much for sure
gonna start off with the switch axe
because after playing blood-borne like
having like a trick type weapon it's
pretty sweet to me yeah switch X they
also do a lot of really cool things to
change it oh hey don't mind me do two
just come on this way over yonder get a
move on how do we know it's safe it's
definitely not safe in that we are
following this monster up the hill sand
sandy pie we're playing the full release
the full sorry we're playing the full
version of the game it's not actually
out in the wild for everyone else or out
in public yet until I would say tomorrow
not either 9 piece 9 p.m. Pacific which
would be 12:00 a.m. Eastern someone
would have to double-check that for me
if not is probably midnight tomorrow
yeah so let's not sit underneath the
t-rex and definitely run away oh that's
the other cool part is watching monsters
kind of like running on each other and
be like hey no fu it's like my territory
but it's also like like in actuality
it's one of the coolest things because
like there's you'll you'll be fighting a
thing and then a dude comes in you're
like oh I'll just sit back and watch it
happen then for some reason they get
smart and then the bull start coming at
you and you've got a like tricking and
hitting each other like wait a second
what about that good cool see ya man
yeah so we're coming up into the the
main town here
gube she right into which has a question
which are the preferred weapon classes
for this game most commonly used
I think preferred is tough because it's
like what you end up wanting to use but
like what do you what would you say are
comp like the most commonly used weapons
um or is that even a thing I I feel like
like longsword great sword kind of like
the the signature weapons even like
Monster Hunter with those probably are
the most common yeah I can't say with
certainty though yeah I mean like like
again the good part is you'll be able to
kind of mess around with all those
weapons feel them out and there's a
pretty good right like in terms of like
just the variety of weapons there's a
pretty good variety they're so fast up
in SLO weapons range weapons
so it really comes down to like your
preference your personal preference and
you know maybe you get really good with
one weapon then you're like hey I should
I'm gonna go try that other weapon now
because like I was kind of curious about
it got a pretty good handle on this one
like that's kind of like the beauty of
it is you can kind of switch on a whim
now granted you're gonna have to craft
some of that stuff down the road but why
spend some of the time in the beginning
maybe just training area or just using
it on monsters and seeing how you like
them I guess yeah it's and they do a
pretty good job of offering you like
down the road like oh man I've been
hunting this and I can make an easier to
craft hit restoring shield is a perfect
beginner weapon yeah Peter ended up
swapping that and he really liked that
one now just to preface there is like
kind of like there's like one small
sword and small shield and then there's
like one that's like the charged blade
which is also technically sort of shield
but then also morphs into a great it
like a big axe yeah so can you do a
wield guns as an option no at least not
currently there's only for a long time
dude I didn't think I would want to play
with the gun Lance yeah but that looks
like a crazy time man dude yeah like at
first when uh John Luke was describing
it to me cuz I hadn't seen it yet I'm
like oh yeah like squall you know like
that you know like yeah but it's like no
it's like a really big ass like it's
like the great sword size but it's like
a gun blade yeah and of like a poker
it's real weird quick reload boom no
problem
yeah so cool got a lot of build up going
on basically I'm gonna just summarize
what he's saying he's like oh hey
welcome to the town I like it figure out
what's going on TLDR this guy will show
you around he's got a really big swords
you know you can trust him Eragon frost
has said that hammer has been his top
three fav hammers always lots of Hunter
games
mr. himer has got some good like moose
eye damage yeah especially with its
charged up yeah it's got that like
barbarian whirlwind essentially it also
has like a really good like once you
kind of down the monster I saw like
because Justin's going pretty much
hammer yeah it's got that kind of just
like a normal hammer motion but like it
just does it repeatedly and then like
the last one just like a huge like
charged swing it looks looks pretty
beefy it's it's not my type of weapon
cuz I've never been huge on like the the
big slow ones but you never know I might
come around cuz of that gun lands yeah
they're also fun and they're all very
different which is yeah also I keep
mentioning it to if if the people who
played Monster Hunter have definitely
play the demo but it's really cool that
like now range is like an actual thing
people can do it's like it I just felt
like at the bow and the bow gun and all
that all of it were there kind of jokes
like on the 3s and everything but now
it's actually fun to play and like it's
super pleasing just all the animations
everything that come along with yeah
adding with the bow they're legit viable
and I think having that having that
knowledge and experience with some of
these other weapons down the road when
you do do kind of group hunts you know
it's gonna be like it's not that you
couldn't all like use a great sword but
like yeah it's it's nice to know that
you're like oh I'm gonna you know use my
bone arrow now or you know use one of
the other range weapons and you can just
go in and you know piss the boss off and
take all the damage while I'm kind of
over here yeah
artillery away almost cuz like 101 was
basically like you're shooting like a
little like missile that goes up and
you're just like kind of like yeah I'm
chillin and I and I think chat had told
me last week to like with a certain
weapon like yeah high ground matters
yeah which is also cool you know you you
always want to be up high just so you
can get that jump and maybe get them out
yeah okay so tell me as a person who's
played all the monster hunters why it's
so important to actually jump on and get
on to the back now the reason why it it
doesn't look like that big of a deal to
me is because it's like you're doing
like one day
one damage one damage so it you you do
the one damage but that's slowly
weakening one targeted area because you
can jump on either the head the back or
the tale depending on which monster
you're fighting okay and you're locating
that damage in that one place so if you
want to get like a tail break you can
sit on the tail hit a whole bunch and if
you get enough hits on it you'll
actually be able to do your like special
finisher move with your weapon okay and
that's where the damage comes in and it
usually gets hard enough to knock them
over which leads into a whole bunch more
damage yeah and also I think that I mean
you can correct me if I'm wrong but like
if you're trying to get a tail piece
like by cutting it off probably
increases your chances to get like a
tails yes okay but cutting the tail off
has a lot of factors like what weapon
you're using how sharp it is yeah what
the monsters need out of I guess but
yeah it's it's a good time and also you
get a special carve from the tail which
is why it's always good to go for the
nice someone had just asked sorry I
missed your name did you play the beta
on ps4 is this running better than that
or this question it's pretty similar but
in places it runs it it does this thing
where if you're fighting a monster and
you're like looking into a corner where
there isn't the rest of the map the game
will like kick into like 60 FPS in it
it's kind of weird did you play mostly
on performance gotcha yeah yeah almost
yeah exactly all of my time has been
spent Oh Patsy 96 the review will drop
I believed 12 a.m. today so today going
into tomorrow and tomorrow we'll be back
then we'll be back I won't
it'll be Ben and John Luke they're gonna
do some later game hunts and we're
hiring stuff and we'll be able to then
show you
Ben's actual like character not this new
one that we made that has like you know
armor and weapon and stuff that you PI
haven't seen yet alright so we're
running around the town we're seeing
stuff we're checking out a room we're
about to build up to a hunt for the the
great sagres yeah which people who have
played the demo no but
so the the charge played as a dirty
monkey has said is a suit is a switch
kind of weapon between a sword and a
tower shield to a giant axe it's a very
solid weapon but yes it is a pretty
technical you need to know what you're
doing I guess I mean it's not
necessarily super complicated but I'm
sure there's efficiencies there of like
how you like min max combos and things
like that because you have to recharge
like pretty much meter to be able to do
stuff in the good damage with the
two-handed mode the two-handed axe
essentially here's here's these weapons
ya picking her our first weapon here I
might might go with that bagpipe light
that's not for me
oh that's alright I might go with the
switch actress cuz you were you're
thinking you might want to attacks
bagpipes an interesting weapon because
it's it's something that like buffs your
party and like be buffs the monster I
think that you you like you swing the
the actual weapon to to like play notes
because the wind is going through the
instrument while you're swinging it and
then after you play like four notes you
press a button to play the whole melody
and it will give you a buff or debuff
kind of thing yeah as astrick cgy has
mentioned this which axis is about bar
efficiency which you'll see in a second
under i think ben's health you do have
to recharge kind of like meter as i had
mentioned earlier to be able to kind of
get that sword to do some nice things
but it's not as complicated i feel as
the charge blade yeah so i'll say i feel
if i mess with the charge blade enough I
could probably yeah I think is one of
those like once you figure out how it
works
it's just becoming like a fighting game
we're like you're getting muscle memory
you're figuring out how to you know get
those charges back what's the best way
to get them there's different tricks I
think cuz like you can even fill the
meter I think from like blocking yeah
which is like pretty cool but like you
know holy tutorial I kind of wish I
could just turn the messages off I
I've been playing a lot of betas yes we
can been so don't quote me I've seen a
lot of options so I don't quote me on
that Louise your stores sorry if I
butchered the last name
can you still play the beta know that
there's no betas in sight the games
about to come out in a pretty much just
do some math 1212
god I'm bad at math in like another 36
hours right it's coming up it's
something like that I can't do math
right now I feel like what math look I
was questioning like the the weird
release date for these like Dragon Ball
and on a Friday but like it's perfect
for just jumping in and then having like
a whole weekend where you can do nothing
but play the games I can't wait be a
good weekend I should just wear my
girlfriend now ahead of time I'm sorry
let me go we go a garage if you're
talking switch axe we're about to use it
Ben has a pretty good handle on using
the switch axe I believe so you'll be
able to see what we're talking about in
just a second it's gonna be kind of not
a great display of it because we're
killing small monsters that's fine but
we can at least so like right now you
can see the meter it's under so there's
like two meters under the two triangles
that that one right below the yellow
blinking triangle is like the sharpness
of your weapon which right and ideally
you want that to be green right the
higher the better you can actually get
it up into blue really and stuff it just
makes it sure okay nice glad that Ben's
here for this cuz I don't got those pro
tips and then there's like another meter
that's right under it that kind of
represents your weapon I want to say
like you know I was watching you can see
a little arrow there as long as you have
it up to that part you'll kind of be
able to do some that that sword stuff
now to get that bar to fill up again all
you have to do is
with the axe or do damage with the axe
right god Lexi says I got Friday off
mind and body is ready
who's you're you're so set I'm gonna
develop a some type of cough that's not
true I I can't do that cuz I told Joey
we do Dragon Ball Fighters on Friday so
I'll be in the office there you go
what am i yeah you got yourself a man
the last time I actually took time off
from from gamespot in my like six years
now yeah it was for Diablo 3 and I got
that hot air 33 or whatever the frickin
stupid air was oh you couldn't even get
in yeah it was a bad time and then like
I was on I was on chat with my friends
this was pre discord by the way man yeah
a ventriloquist
yeah and he was like yeah I mean I'm
like you can't see you can't see across
Ventrilo but I got a special finger for
you so yeah
oh so the other thing that Ben's doing
if you guys are noticing if you haven't
played a monster hunter before is like
he's kind of releasing those flash pods
which are kind of hazing the monsters
here so he can kind of get some damage
in you want to use that down the road to
the environment will help you out here
and there there's like vines that like
can hold down monsters or that's the the
big thing I think in this game is
definitely all the environmental stuff
you can kind of pull into how you're
fighting it's like before you could
climb on stuff and jump off of things
but now you've got like their weapons
they're not weapons like animals that
will cause different effects or like
the the flies that you can hit to kind
of stun it's just there's a lot going on
and it's really cool dirty monkey says
he's also taking Friday off they're
gonna wake up hit up that I pop I hop
sorry for all you can eat pancakes and
then play this all day my tip to you
would be don't go to ham on the pancakes
and then get like food coma and then we
just lose lose time playing a lot of
people saying that weapon o P for sure
you haven't even seen the like elemental
discharge the good stuff yeah you only
saw him trick it let's just do a group
of dinosaurs and spinning no problem oh
it's gonna get good someone wanted like
how it like wanted to know how big the
map was I guess it's imagine like a
previous monster hunter if you can
without any loading screens but it's
it's pretty big in the more importantly
than its being just big is it's it's
super layered like each zone has three
to four levels to it and they all kind
of like fold over on top of each other
yeah well Chris Brennan ven isn't that
old it's just that everyone's gonna is
using discord now or like Skype probably
that like I don't know too many people
there so prevent you speak yes see we
keep going do you ever use mumble oh
yeah yeah mumble was legit people with
it for a while yeah mama was legit man
yeah you've got mail remember came spy
arcade yes all these things I use
teamspeak says Bob Jones still a solid
service I mean like I'm just saying I
would I think most people unless you
were using one of those services before
and all your friends are using it are
probably on discord yeah so it's just
that's just that like the evolution your
discord has taken over it's a very good
very very good service I'm not gonna
upgrade any of this because I don't
think I'm gonna be holding on to this
I might Forge a thing there we go
what we got here what do you make and
get some some cool new armor going do it
I'll do one of these yeah well hunters
male is that it so currently is that
just costing you like currency and not
any parts right so there oh you got some
parts was making sure I got the car
sweet well good sweet carbs yeah don't
forget to carve it's all about the car
that's a big deal you only have X amount
of time after you kill monster did to
get that sweet crafting material that's
like leather hide and stuff and scales
and things and tails and all that stuff
that's the other part too it's like
you're gonna need a Fang and you might
not get it yeah so go hunt again you
gotta go form that stuff dude I want a
Kirito sword that'd be sick dual wield
you can't do a wield in this game though
so they won't the swords won't look are
there
dual wield answer if you can okay are
there dual wield swords that are like
actually like one hands different from
the other you only might actually be the
better John Luke I saw you in chat
because if you have that question he's
been playing with the dual swords so you
might know better do you know if there's
perfect block still with charge wait I
know charge blade okay there you go Shan
Xing so I only know certain things about
the charge blade because my my roommate
plays it all the time which is why I
didn't touch it yeah so I think the the
if you I'm guessing if you perfect block
you probably refill five of the the
little jars or what I don't know what
they're called but like yeah John Luke
said mister what about dual blades is
there a dual blade in the game that has
like your left hand and your right hand
actually look like different swords you
know kind of like a yin and a yang kind
of thing that cut Sudan kerfuffle
perfect yep let's do that gonna fight
fight these dudes again
are we oh yeah only not the not the same
ones that's okay yeah you gotta get some
of the small guys out of the way first
another tip for sure is if you haven't
played in Monster Hunters you definitely
want to eat before you go hunt yes as I
have learned but if you're looking for a
beginner's guide so to speak we're gonna
have one I think in the coming days John
Luke's working on that so stay tuned for
that if you that's you know for the
people that haven't played Monster
Hunter I'm sure it's gonna help me quite
a bit yeah one time see people talking
about the difficulty in the game I've
been playing high rank for a while so
this is no problem
don't worry about if you think the game
is going to be easy if if you are don't
be it's still a very challenging game
it's still all there okay so John Luke
says he has a pair of rapiers with
different color blades but I haven't
seen anything that yet like yet that
looks completely different that's close
enough
Kirito they're different colors sort of
different swords but that's fine close
enough don't skip the palico cooks it's
hilarious okay maybe next time oh I love
you I let the first one go and I I know
people are trying to like get back into
the game what are you doing so I was
trying to rush along
should I come out on your own you're
doing a hell of a job
careful Ben
he might actually be real careful right
up he's dead
give me the hot stuff yeah I don't care
I want it bang yep now the cool thing is
I've seen it where I guess depending on
the situation like it'll kind of stick
into like the monsters neck I'm still
trying to figure out how to do that yeah
well one of the ways as you had
mentioned is what if you do jump on the
back you get it enough times in here on
the head like that we'll just like
you'll jam that into his neck and like
it'll just do like the kind of like
almost like King Saul you motion yeah
and then explode which is like Oh Bruno
it's good to see you
sold me sold me on that weapon that was
that was like that all all right switch
axe here we go a lot of fun I'm not
trying to troll you guys but could you
slightly increase the volume I'm having
trouble hearing you guys yes I got you I
got you
okay it's when it's glowing that makes
sense
uh I like that thank you look I've
played this game for so many hours I'm
just so learning things it's like it's
Monster Hunter I love it yeah I mean
part of that variety comes with the the
weapons right so it was sorry glowing
when oh so when when you get a couple of
hits the whole weapon will start to glow
and I guess that's when we know what a
little latch on oh okay that's good to
know I needed I needed to know that
that's that's what I'm that's the hot
tip switch axe best axe I know right
just a we stay here and take the beating
although I uh I do know that the sword
does more deeps than the actual axe yeah
cannon fodder 2 per one special violin
get was afraid it's it's all about the
so as you can see as he's swinging the
axe version he's kind of building up
that sword meter essentially or the
ability to kind of use the sword for
longer right in the butt easy no problem
right learning new things in a monster
hunter never said believe it - I like
how there's a was actually like an
initiative out there right now for like
Monster Hunter veterans to kind of like
mobster hunterson people and like teach
them how the game works I think it's
actually being a thing that sanctioned
by Capcom oh really which is kind of we
have a story about it on the site but I
know someone who's who's one of the
people who's mentoring but it's a pretty
good community and I'm kind of stoked I
keep saying I'm really stoked for people
to play this game lahar oh Rick's asking
how many missed solo missions you have
to do before the coop uh we just
unlocked it so that's pretty fast
the first mission after oh just after
the first one okay that's pretty fast
cool one day four hours and 11 minutes
just keep that constant update nice
thank you you need that oh here's your
boy oh yeah oh so that's why his that
makes votes now no because I've only
seen him oh really that way really yes
I've only I was like like a bloat toad
thing you know but I wrecked him in beta
cuz you know you just got Opie stuff
yeah I mean relative to what he is
because he's like one of the the first
kind of like okay so how much of how
much does that help cuz I was asking
John Luke kind of about that like so you
can track the footsteps you track kind
of like although like to help you find
the monster better but it also gives you
like was that P points what are those so
leveling up the points actually gives
you different benefits for tracking okay
so after us
point in time I've had it where I
actually drop right on the monster when
I start a quest Wow
which is that's insane real weird okay
and those are Scout flies for you that
don't know that which will help guide
you yeah which is I like the the way
that hunts work out in this game a lot
more than the old ones because you
actually like you find the tracks and
you you kind of move around because
before you just run around until someone
was like oh I found it it's in zone 11
everyone get over here and you're like
oh yes this is it but now you can
actually kind of poke around you be like
oh I know that it'll be around like
these wooded areas so I'll start like
checking for footprints and you find
footprints which lead to like weird
stuff on the ground that tie to them and
you can eventually have the Flies point
out where they are after you find a
couple okay that quality old life
exactly yes this game's gonna be on ps4
as well as Xbox PCs gonna come later
this year the developer did say why I
did not read why though so apologies Sam
there are lot of people who are are
guessing that like oh the PC version is
coming later and it might end up being
like that oh okay okay that makes just
like G rank stuff might get added later
or something someone say PLC for that
one yeah yeah
so what looks weak to you here in in
terms of his body part Oh everything's
this is a squishy boy
I see I don't even know if you can get a
tail car probably can but like
everything just kind of everything just
kind of hurts him
hello like that yeah oh here comes the
business and get right up in there oh
isn't this the the splode II also it's
it's kind of weird like going back to to
the basic way that everything kind of
worked oh I probably get the so another
really big thing they added to this game
is the sliding you can actually go from
a slide into a like a mouth nice you you
launch off up into the air when you
[Music]
really because davit move to its face
okay brace and stab stab stab embrace go
to sleep you got it we got to be coming
up real close on it come on any minute
now there we go oh here is he yeah
and mental discharge knocks it down then
you get some more fun damage bring it in
switch one to finish it's okay so this
should latch on do it yeah okay we're
learning oh it goes oh no not yet it
just felt like a good cinematic moment
so can i play as a cat no but your cat
is your buddy for life unless you have
three people in your Aragon frost saying
switch axe and Charlie will be okey I
feel like a lot of love weapons wolf you
could argue our Oh P depending on how
you look at it so I think just pick the
weapon that you want to play or he'll
just experiment with all of them and
have yourself a good old time I mean it
it does you will have to kind of pick
later I mean in some sense because you
you know you have to you'll you'll have
kind of craft your weapon you know but
still all that it's good time yeah yeah
as asterisk cgy sorry I just might know
how to say your name but he said all the
weapons are viable somewhere and that is
that's true I'm even bagpipes I've seen
is like pretty legit if you know what
you're doing with it support weapon know
someone penis remains it oh nice so
that's gonna be really fun by having
them yeah what kind of bus do you get do
you know you know it's like a tack
defense oh my no like
does it stack on top like the food okay
way their way if you're not if you're
missing something from the food you're
gonna get benefits yeah basically you're
you're barred you liked playing support
yeah
60 seconds to to carve them and here
we've finished our first actual monster
no problem it's a good team give me that
give me give me some it was it was asked
that gave that hint for ya you've
changed my game what's what Jax now whoa
I feel so complete I feel like that
little bit yeah but was missing and now
it's there now it's like you can't get
enough of it now exactly now I miss what
Jax boy I know but that's the beauty of
it cuz like once you start like learning
to master those weapons is like is there
a way to even make this even better
there might be you know so like
optimizing your combos and whatnot but
definitely shoot shoot I don't still
learning a bed maybe I accidentally got
it at some point maybe I've never cut
the tail I mean the first couple
monsters aren't going to be as difficult
difficulty I'm just assuming ramps up as
you point so also like like I said
earlier I'm 70 hours into this game like
I yeah that felt awesome but seemed a
bit OPI I mean think about this thirst
monster yeah look if you hadn't played
before like someone like me I probably
wouldn't have slid and mantled I
probably would have effed up those
button prompts I probably wouldn't have
been able to optimally do the like thing
where it glowed and then the you know
kind of like the like finisher like
where it sticks into his neck like and
that would have made it seem probably
less opie you know like I've heard
people say that like the beginning fight
in a game will take them like the whole
40 or 50 minutes but like I know what
I'm doing so I was able
should've watch me play Demon Souls and
fight that first boss which everyone
said was the easiest boss and it took me
a good 10 to 15 minutes at least yeah
they're like is that you just boss I'm
like yeah I've never played this I don't
know what I'm doing right now insect
glaive is awesome I agree jester
I like insect glaive it's a good time I
sure must know will there be a rathalos
I can say yes because it was in the beta
6 it showed up as a bonus monster while
you're fighting the engine ass someone
on the stream and now I have a pre-order
I'm happy - you hopefully we convinced
that other person - yes I hope that a
lot of people give this game a try
because it's a good time well I think
this is the best well if you it's not
necessarily the best chance in the sense
that ok yeah I guess it's not coming out
to PC but this is gonna give it like a
really solid opportunity compared to
like it being on handheld cuz I was
never gonna play it handheld I'll be
honest and I can't say that about
everyone else in chat or everyone else
else out there but that had to be a
barrier whereas like you know if you're
putting in on a pretty on - pretty
mainstream consoles there's gonna be a
bigger user base there yeah that are
gonna be interested and it's early in
the year when usually that's kind of
more quiet in terms of like game
releases so I think it's coming out at a
great time you know one playing co-op
can you craft things for your friends
asks whoa the chat just went too fast I
sorry I missed the name you you cannot
craft things for your friends you can't
trade parts either there was a time
where I thought you could because it
showed up but you can't but I also saw
someone asked is there stories of just
hunting monsters I feel like this is the
first time there is like an actual story
story which is like I was saying earlier
kind of weird but yeah there's there's a
plot driving you through yelling stuff
just pre-ordered says Vegeta tweets
three one zero do you think it'll come
out on switch there's an article today
talking about that I feel like yeah that
it's probably not for like a while and
there was a reason why and I didn't look
it up so I apologize but that is a spot
on exactly games.com there it is out
there
I mean to help you to Evie sweet thanks
everyone hanging out doing stuff yeah
thanks for the tips coming through
thanks for the questions we really
appreciate it
Aragon frost says you gotta you guys
convinced me from earlier great streams
so far very informative thank you for
the kind words we really appreciate it
really appreciate you guys all hanging
out today as we go through some of the
beginning parts of Monster Hunter world
I'm looking forward to it oh yeah that's
that's another great point sorry to cut
you off yeah um there's gonna be like
all those like cool like like Capcom and
slash like at least for Sony like
crossover stuff with like a LOI and
stuff like that I'm looking forward to
that as well it's gonna be a good time
but this is also a really big thing that
people who've played a lot of Monster
Hunter will probably be really excited
about just like I was the upgrade trees
are actually laid out like trees now and
you don't have to have like a wiki open
to find out like what goes into what
it's all laid out so you can be like I'm
gonna upgrade my switch axe and it'll
upgrade it you equip it it's good and
then you can see like oh if I if I go
down this route I can eventually build
in something that does lightning damage
or if I want to continue fighting the
great jag hrus I can get three more
scales and I'll be able to build the
Jaguars axe nice which has a nice little
hint there you know that it's you know
that version get the bone got the bone
tree all the different stuff for that
and how does that other stuff
progression to the game or start getting
other like material you craft or buy a
bone axe and then it'll just be based
off of instead of going in mining stuff
it's off of like monster bones you find
in piles okay and then you just kinda go
that way and they have different stats
and different different builds and stuff
but they're basically the same weapon
outside of that oh so you just Morgan
bonus yeah nothing like a lock in lucky
vouchers and cool boxes this guy get a
quests you want to switch your weapon
even though you just made anyone yeah I
guess right now in chat while he's
scrolling through tell me what you want
to see hopefully it's one that bends
I'll pick and choose what you want to
actually know fine I don't want
I don't want like it which ones do you
know then so then I can kind of then I
can kind of like say hey chat I was kind
of in the back of my head wanting to
show off one of the range so I feel like
alright let's do that let's do that yeah
yeah yeah let's it's it's really cool
just to show them that is also viable
I'm like you said it's more useful this
time around compared to previous Monster
Hunters I think that's I think that's a
good shout yeah we'll do that for the
next hunt so pretty cool stuff that's
registers some bounties really quick
bounties I love me bounties bone piles
shirt get insects mining outcrops pick
up some honey grab some plants and sure
mushrooms why not yeah we love mushrooms
so the crafting is pretty pretty cool
too and like there's like I think the
one time saver down the road too is that
you can like awed it like set things to
auto craft too which is pretty cool oh
yeah yeah it's like oh I haven't sent
where we're going iron bow yeah if if I
pick up you get you get potions at the
beginning of each we got your chat
everyone said bow like most people said
bow most people or more more people said
both anything else are those like daily
bounties or is that just tutorial stuff
oh so those are while you're out doing
it's kind of like on top of what you're
already doing beside you like little
side things you'll get one that's like
Gohan three Fang monsters and you
basically just have it up while you're
doing your regular stuff and it'll give
you extra bonuses for finishing it io
max saying I would love if you could if
players could change directions there in
combos I often strike air because the
monster moves while I'm in a combo so if
if that's a difficult thing for you the
weapon that I kind of learned to get
around that with is the the long sword
the long sword is a really good like
beginner friendly weapon I feel because
there's a lot of you can kind of twist
and turn a little bit at least while
you're you're fighting and also they
give you like an offensive defensive
kind of maneuver that you can do if you
press circle and triangle where you kind
of sidestep while you swipe your sword
so you can kind of use that to
reposition and kind of get a better beat
on whatever you're trying to fight
I recommend the longsword if you don't
like that also I recommend don't use the
lock on a lot of people think that the
lock on yeah helps I am nosing I learned
that real quick I was you know having
not played a monster hunter and knowing
that there is lock on because they tell
you there's lock on I started using it I
was like oh this kind of is not good
like and I used lock on some for so many
like like blood-borne Dark Souls and it
was like you know what do you expect but
like in this game it's not as good I
would say but John Luke did mentioned
and I think maybe it was just into that
sometimes if you are in the air though
lock-on helps for that stuff but yeah
for the most part you probably probably
want to just like aim yourself I guess
like I haven't locked on the entire time
we've been playing something they just
get used to essentially um yeah I just
did Ben's mic I might be a little louder
now so just tell me if that's too much
for you guys
I'm trying no you're good it's on lion I
got to do it oh I got it I'll fix it
don't worry
gotcha I got you yeah so we're heading
out and do an expedition to try and find
a new campsite where's gonna hello ah
gross just hanging out dude what's there
see you but yeah yeah there's no time
limit on the expedition it's correct
yeah expeditions you basically kind of
look at like a monster forecast I guess
and like oh cool the great jaggus is
gonna be in town today I guess I'm gonna
go and hunt them and you don't have like
a time limit you don't have a cart limit
and you can kind of just go and kill
stuff someone had mentioned they're
scared there's not gonna be too many
monsters there are a lot of monsters
there you go there's a lot of a lot of
monsters confirmed I want to say and
don't quote me on this I think someone I
coulda sworn I heard like over 40 or at
least 40 there's only that list okay we
can talk about and speculate about that
has like 40 to 50 on it okay yeah lotta
monsters lotta monsters can you befriend
the monsters you can catch them they can
capture them I don't know if that's as
good as befriend in but it's an option
pacifist
too bad you can't be because you need
their you need that new scales for pants
please give me the pants all of the
pants uh yeah and the other things I
think you can talk about this that
that's kind of cool is like you're
telling me because I was like dude which
arm where do I go cuz this is all about
fashion you know it's all about that
fashion line yeah don't worry even if
something you just got a pic what looks
good and then you just are more spirit
yeah basically and you can kind of keep
a set around for a good amount of time
also just as good Armour spirit and keep
it up anyway is that are those hard to
come by or is it just they don't happen
a lot at first but then you you get them
from the bounties and you also can get
them from finishing the higher level
quests so they're their thing you can do
oh the fisherman's here oh hey howdy so
he gives you fishing quests Ghats ocean
I'm not sure is there trans Long's in
the game not that I have seen also high
gets it's good to see you yeah there you
go uh let's see well like scorpion in
mortal combat no everyday I've been
asked do I know the way
it's the our chat memes nine and
different spellings of that too I love
it yeah how much customization is
offered we we showed customization
earlier in the stream for your character
in terms of armor they give you a pretty
good amount of like kind of messing with
how you want to build your character but
it's it's still like here's an armor set
it does these things and you kind of
hunt down whatever set you feel like you
want oh there's another person over here
I I'm just going to the the campsite
that I remember I didn't know if I just
says find one right yeah
so let's hoping I could poke around and
maybe find a different one but we're not
trying to explore too much that's fine
you know what the people want because we
were camped more monster murder yeah we
didn't pick this bow for nothing exactly
found it give me the campsite please
well this game so bad we're so close so
close feel you I feel you so much every
day I mean I have massive FOMO right now
just just give me the game please
transmog question mark transmog or
transmogrification is where like in
World of Warcraft or maybe other games
where you can make something look like
something else but still keep the stats
of the thing that you have equipped so
like I have this chest piece on right
now and I like the stats on it and I
want to make it look like the one that
he has on I can actually take like break
it down and then turn it into that
physically but it still retains the
stats of what I have on Congress no
you're you're pellicle pal is the same
size the whole way through they don't
get older well maybe an age but not in
appearance write that up like don't get
bigger they don't get there exactly we
have to get cool different armor sets
and they look adorable mm-hmm I can't
speak too much about dies unfortunately
don't know too much there and or maybe
in in Maus 104 they had a thing we hit
high rank and you could change color
nice okay so hopefully we're hoping the
mechanical price stay the same because
I'm all about the fashion you want to
you want to figure out about all the
cool stuff that happens late in the game
tune in tomorrow yeah if you want to
know that okay so this is the first hour
give or take and tomorrow when the
embargoes up tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. John
Luke our boy Ben here will be back
showing off some late game or higher
rank hunts some late game you know
armors weapons what they've collected so
far and yeah tune in for that one as
well maybe a good time it'll be a good
time that's when we talk about the deep
stuff exactly deep knowledge you're
trying to be trying to be respectful of
cool embargoes and such oh give me the
doodles apparently mr. Smith says
transmog is in the game because the
samurai said for the deluxe edition is a
transmog mm-hmm that could be a thing me
don't have deluxe
same min/max says I love auda GaN he's
so cute a lot of kissing face oh my gosh
yeah look at him just running around wow
he's a lot faster than you yeah you know
it's not a surprise
rip playing as Pella codes yeah sorry
they do stuff to help you though a lot
of cool stuff it ran off this way and
I'm checking like its usual I'm so sorry
I have not been helping you I know you
look like I'm literally little camp
you're you're doing what you guys you're
talking other people and that's what
that's what we need I know Dylan Smith
yes 12 a.m. Thursday which is like in
less than 12 hours now our review and
the rest of the reviews of the world
will be out so stay tuned for that
oh it's off that way it's it's got it
already marked but it's not tracking it
okay are you packing a monster right now
yes so we went under the the campsite
and there's a cool uyoku who's hanging
out there sweet so now we've got to hunt
them down they were literally right
behind this tree the whole time sneaky
bastards can't believe it what up my
dude it's good to see you
have a seat please power in the kisser
it's gonna charge me up and get this off
no I don't believe baby we did it so if
you guys notice in the bottom right he
has like right now he's using close
range coatings but there's you know
other ones that he could eat here all
the power powers in it Odin probably
like breakfast thing whoo you know what
you need to calm down sir I also
realized that I hadn't on the Sun
because I forgot that you end up having
hon something tastes fine but yeah
there's a bunch of other coatings and
stuff you'll be able to craft at some
point oh this guy's got rock now oh did
you just do the little cluster bomb
thing yeah yeah that's okay no I can do
that like on command which is kind of
nice but is it essentially like a dodo
whoa he's kind of he's kind of a joke
monster but I like him a lot
he's got a lot of personality yeah run
away I dare you go go away from here
Oh Oh got him just little bit one damage
it's all good though don't shoot him
he's a beautiful dragon now we have to
the game is telling us we have to so you
know and here we are sorry bro
he's trying to hang out in our camping
spot we can't have that no how much you
want to bet the jaggis is gonna show up
here Ennis I wouldn't be shocked I was
about to say I think he's fine like
trying to find a friend prone to like
help out like a oh man I don't want to
fight this dude by myself
kind of make this a terrible time for
you
oh yeah no state stay in the rocks
no can't believe this bad cool there we
go
bet that rock out of there so apparently
the bow
according to chat the other day is all
about charging so I've found that it's
more like a shoot twice and then do the
the charged shots like a 1 2 3 because
it adds extra shots every time you get a
shot off it's been working all right for
me yeah I like that but charging is
definitely good if anyone's got the pro
strats yeah you're missing hello you got
from me from anything let me know cuz
I'm down I'm all about it so you do like
one of these and then it should do like
that like that pow
that's that's my jam cow just pulling on
Wilson yeah yesterday I had to although
it made more sense yesterday yeah yeah
oh oh oh no yeah I got stung
it was real bad it's okay though because
now we can now we can eat something yeah
so we didn't eat before turns out we
needed to eat and because this isn't an
expedition I'm not uh I don't have a
cart limit we're just kind of nice take
defense just just to be safe yeah it
gives me more stats correct yeah that's
what happens what happens the guy had a
rock those are rock I couldn't do
anything else on my eyes this bow is not
my bow it's someone else's bow yeah they
got us off our strong switch axe game
exactly
yeah the the slinger makes them drop the
rock you've got to have the ammo for the
slinger though which I didn't pick up
yet which is kind of foolish of me but
it was fine
oh I see the significance of the rock
now the rock the rock isn't the thing to
mess around with when he throws it it's
very serious I think he uses it the
block attacks you I feel like yeah
unless I was like accidental but it
seemed like he meant it
it's like a shield kind of kind of deal
looking good over there
oh there we go well that one did
multiple hits despite you not I also
think it's based off your stamina
somehow like I still own entirely under
so like on the left's around the top
left rather yeah go fight it out akan
he's tired small asleep taking it taking
the nap for a second there we go got him
broke that that middle of his body I
guess what do you have to offer
stay there that was me I did not it
felts meaty enough you know that like oh
he's digging for rocks no he's got his
head stuck okay now's the perfect time
might be because I'm using the
close-range coating now actually yeah
you're also out of the stamina yeah
death by chicken dinner oh no it came
full circle oh there is we hold it out
know what The Rock is cooking oh there's
the great Jagger us hanging out coz one
monster wasn't enough now yacht - oh he
done eating - good god oh my god he's
doubled in size
sorry he's real slow now
that's good which is out of time he's
got your back he's just sticking it out
layer hanging out Oh see you know he's
got the rock it's a rock boy it's my one
weakness can you smell what The Rock is
cooking maybe sometimes I do get out of
my way no I want to play I'll see you
later did too much to eat good god why
Otacon don't why not cuz we're Merrill
is short for at aku Convention oh no ha
ha got ya so I don't want to deal with
that at all I want to stay away from
that completely
oh there's some goop on the wall Larry's
back now it's a party
yeah all right he's Larry's trying to
find us hey Mikey how's it going
grandpa we're currently playing on a
regular in riri but most of the other
folks out in the pits the video pits and
editorial pits are playing on that pro
life you just giimpse Ben cuz I don't
know I kind of was at a pond I'm like
I'll take a ps4 just any ps4 oh we got
that that back set from the shop that I
completely whiffed it's fine hello I
don't want you here at all no one wants
you here it's a big big monster it's a
really big monster
he will definitely one-shot me if he
breathes fire on me go kill it for us I
think it's actually gonna run away I
don't think it's gonna stick around and
try to fight it I think you should try
fighting you know so we can watch oh no
he's my god Ben yeah okay we're not dead
George
yeah aha now we're dead yeah mm-hmm well
so that's why you don't mess around with
uh the monster you're supposed to fight
like fifteen hours into the game yeah
it's running pretty well I haven't seen
any hiccups or anything it's it's
definitely doesn't run as well as like
the pro version but it it's manageable
it's he wrecked get got that's like I
can't eat now because apparently glitter
nuke says there's no ultimate version
explicitly explicitly said by Capcom
take your word for it is oh I feel like
at some point there might be but you
know we don't know trihard black eye I
don't think he has any other coatings
right now so he's just kind of stuck
yeah using the clothes this early game
we just put that we just literally clip
the bow to kind of showcase a different
weapon it's trying to get away from this
guy and not be anywhere near him I feel
like I put Ben in a corner that's fine
and no one puts been in the corner so
track down this silly looking
dodo bird owner or slash wrap they're
thinking ibrid we don't want anymore
done do not that's for sure
he's behind me did we go into his home
we might be headed towards it like that
yeah is that our boy yeah there he is
hanging out fine get that so we can get
that mount on him silver just came up to
close it's not let me do it that's fine
you know what we don't need it
he's got rock so maybe if you're new to
Monster Hunter maybe I would say don't
use the bow to start yeah I still think
that the longsword is really good
beginner weapon yeah
it's faster than that great sword the
duel goodreads a really good sword and
shield that someone I mentioned yeah I
didn't switch axe is fine weapons once
you once you learn how to get between
the two modes it it becomes kind of kind
easy then you get all the nuance stuff
like the charge hit where you like climb
up on them
go to sleep come on just running away
and he's limping ah that's okay I'll
just shoot this over here really quick
there's a reason I was like oh cool
Ben's gonna track him no nope just
following them all the way down bend the
knee bow is better than group time oh
yeah I could see that I would say the
range stuff is probably hard to start
with Sola if you don't know what you're
doing the really fun thing with range
when you're in a group though is because
you have people who are actually able to
take the attention of the monster you're
able to do more damage but that means
that you're gonna definitely pull more
threat so you'll be sitting there going
like oh this is this is really good I'm
getting late and all of a sudden the
thing turns around and looks at you
you're like well I guess I'm dead now
you used to trap above him I mean that
one
don't worry muddy fun star just trying a
new weapon we will switch soon enough
someone said they used to charge blade I
think Ben said he's just moderately okay
with that weapon yeah I don't want to
figure it out I don't know what very so
I'm gonna I'm gonna go with longsword as
his next swapping weapon to I guess or
maybe another weapon that you feel
comfortable with as long sword might be
good just cuz I've been talking it up so
much yeah talking about and you get to
do that sweet like slam dunk airman yeah
the new move the Edit for this game is
one of my favorite things I got rock
this guy should be here in a second
you lied that was the second shoot
called out kimbos cut tails off yes oh
oh they can there you go it's usually
with a better bow and one that is you
know got more ammo types there's a
slicing no that's for for gun slicing
shots for guns but yeah you can you can
shoot tails
with a bow it's usually with this shot
that it works okay uh we got a tip they
said if you get carded get poison that's
a good call
yeah I get poisons from camp chest if
you do get oh so there aren't anything
in the the chest okay guys it's an
exhibition all right okay which is kind
of a not great thing but there we go so
you know we we used the slinger ammo to
knock the rock out of its hands there we
go now he's still kicking man oh yeah
higher he's on the way out though man
just leave me alone
whoa somehow he missed which is
fortuitous oh it's it's all calculated
everything I'm doing right now is I know
all right super calculated there we go
all right on to the longsword Venn let's
do it I'm gonna get these parts off of
him really quick though I know it's
dropped I'm feeling it
there was a berries above him to shoot
yeah there's probably like one of the
things you can load in like up up here
somewhere you just drop it on him and do
a thing but nice I got time for that I
got time for shooting shooting and
looting all the time mmm oh and I can
just get out of here
the monster gets weaker and more tired
as you you know continue to fight it
that's why it was kind of keeled over
there yeah
do not fear we will show you the long
sword it's like one of them here
one of his uh one of your go twos I
would say I'm only a silence for our
fallen dokdo dose or sure was that long
enough yeah yeah I think you can get
into this decently easily daily bits
I've never played a monster hunter and
I'm looking forward to playing it
obviously you know weapons are gonna be
your first kind of thing to deal with in
terms of like which one you want to use
and how complex some of them are so just
kind of get used to them and don't get
frustrated I guess it's kind of like you
learn more and you continue to learn
more has been even learned more today
I'm still learning yeah
excellent boat play I appreciate that
cuz I felt like it was it wasn't the
best show of it but if if it was alright
I thought it was alright it I didn't
think it was bad I didn't think it was
great having that that low salmon tub
definitely messed with me it wasn't it
wasn't like your switch axe performance
so exactly I've also been using a switch
acts like a lot in my actual playthrough
nice I'll be honest with you yeah I
appreciate I appreciate the honesty
well Shadow the reading we reading every
chat all at once the next monster we're
gonna need some hot anti poison no man
thanks for the tip Bruce had me
yo that map says rake grabbed at this
stuff really quick she's a long sword
there we go
and we'll go talk to the commander Oh
hold on
yeah pcs gonna be a hot minute so it
comes out we did it we beat the game oh
wow it's that's the most important thing
yep mm-hmm could see that just in case
anyone was wondering if I am sky welcome
to the chat Thank You mr. dreadful nose
it's all about the the Pugi okay we're
the ones to get it done and of course
separate ways oh no no two leaders
leaving me all asses see if you can
answer it who's Manning said I heard
there won't be any loading screens does
that mean that all the levels maps will
be joined together and not like the beta
where you had to choose a quest or to
get to a new map so there there's still
zones like different biomes but once
you're inside of that biome you don't
have to load it all with our new extinct
God the pigs are in yeah right it's a
very important thing to time oh it's yes
this boy that it's the the Pooky Pooky
Pooky Pooky do you need that hot anti
poison you know probably but I'm gonna
go uh why not go without in my weapon
the Lance we can only show some many if
I can equip every weapon possible and
show it off all at once
I would Shakib the game comes out
tomorrow at 12 a.m. which would be
Friday technically but did Thursday
Thursday to Friday 12 p.m.
Luffy zakat says thank you for the
preview more eager to play now one more
day to wait thanks for tuning in we
appreciate it yeah yeah and we
appreciate the kind words we're gonna
eat some fish some kebabs some meat
cheese sometimes siliceous oh I'm glad
you feed you kept your your cat your bud
well he's got to eat he's got to get his
Guzzi that statue oh I am going to Kobe
mochi says thanks for the heads-up on
gtfo yesterday any ID
if it's on all consoles no idea I mean
that was such as I just like a teaser
type thing during video game where it's
hard to say what's gonna be I would
imagine all three but you never know I
have a feeling it's gonna be very
similar to payday kind of like a lot of
for other games but mm-hmm but it's like
for dead babies a good time I like
coming to sleep soon yeah I don't which
I have no idea how that's gonna I don't
know how I'm going to play on I don't
know if I will play it on the switch
I've been playing around with the VR
mode in it a bit which is a weird time
other games mean asking what's the best
weapon for a total newb to the series
well we're doing long started I think
longswords a good option sword and
shields good option which which sword is
it just called
what's the easier sword and shield
called is it just sword into you I think
it's just sortin to you okay cool
charges is the other one yeah all right
so we've got all this we're we're good
to go let's hunt this boy down let's do
it
got some weather conditions happening
now it's raining everything is all what
like it what else is there besides his
neck next hunt the hunt is the life hunt
there is nothing after the hunt it's
just the hunt
maybe the expedition you can do
expeditions any time hunts let's keep
going hunts don't stop we're fine
Peter cornfield says that guess why my
fear is this looks repetitive never
played once 100 before but is there any
more to this than hunt town a craft
repeat in a very basic level it is just
kind of hunt town craft repeat but it's
the different factors and kind of like
the way that the fights can play out
differently that is what kind of drives
you because the game is is the hunt yeah
if if you like I keep trying to avoid it
because I don't want to keep being like
if you like Dark Souls there's a lot of
stuff you can kind of like pull over to
here but like if you really like that
feeling of when you beat a boss and Dark
Souls it's just that feeling over and
over again and I will say like there's
layers of complexity as I mentioned
throughout the stream which is
trying to hone in and master a weapon
getting better at that weapon and then
that's that in itself is at least for me
gonna be fulfilling I know
and then like there's you know 14
weapons in total so you could in theory
then try the next weapon yeah
and as someone else in chat mentioned to
the game gets a lot more fun with
playing with other people yeah you can
either match make with or party up with
and then it becomes like the memories
and the experiences that you have with
your friends like remember that one time
when the pew Cape UK was like all up on
you and I was sitting there laughing I
was just laughing at you from across the
way something that the game have weather
changes question mark we got we got
different weather confirmed yep it hurts
me to see that I have a weapon that
starting out has yellow durability this
is kind of killing me a little bit
inside yeah
welcome to being a low ranked hunter
again we are this is already going a lot
better I feel like I spent a lot of time
with the long surgeon have you go
I can't I could not tell it's it's a
weapon that wait wait till you sleep the
good stuff
oh god you have it and you haven't seen
him do the good stuff yeah there we go
that heal I probably do one of those
yeah yeah bring it back down mmm me
likey it's a good time that's the other
new move that the added end yeah break
this dude come down what are you doing
I'm here come get me see if you can
reach me now boys these poison know he's
got the boys yeah I turned the tables
ooh
trying to scrape ukb puke a he's he's
just sitting right in there spinning
around like I I don't know what to tell
him
this is way better than destiny huh no
my love what has happened to you yeah so
my friend that plays a lot destiny and
also played Dark Souls like kind of like
in a way push me over the edge because
he was like Monster Hunter at least for
him reminding him a lot a lot of like
you know the Dark Souls as you had
mentioned and the Destiny elements and I
was like huh I like both of those like
all these things sounds like something
I'd be into yeah yeah I'm gonna do it
it's it's a good time someone said cut
its tail if possible oh I'm gonna try to
get that tail carve thank you
yeah destiny players did jump to the
division just because the divisions been
having some bigger updates just say good
on them can't get this again haha got
the music in this game is so good too
we're saying turn it up got it just
crank it just max keep going weak spot
is the tail we're trying to chop it off
we're doing always go for that tail cut
[Music]
my - don't run away from me I just got
here
see you later Ben uh don't mind me just
sit here and sharpen my sword up only
goes to yellow feels bad it's not it's
it's not even sharp
hey it's not even sharp well would you
say it is this is like a butter knife
right now I'm fighting this ain't gonna
kill it with the butter that's me I
believe this even a B he says I hope
they all have all the classic bosses
like the tigress Narga and all the other
elders tune in tomorrow just find out
tomorrow some of the monsters you might
be looking for as Ben will be on his
70-hour character instead of his like
now what powder knife real butter knife
yeah
blade stallion says would the long sort
cause a lot of hits on teammates it
would but it seems like we've kind of
minimized how much it interferes go a
lot of this game has got a lot of like
quality-of-life stuff in it
oh no you're poisoned I was trying to go
do a whole fight without getting got
once and I messed it up well you have
ten more so it's fine yeah there we go
is this game better than DBZ Dragonball
Fighters that's I hear though how can
you compare them I think they're both a
lot of fun yeah I think if you're on a
limited budget then it depends on what
you think you'll get more out of this
one obviously oh yeah this will
obviously last you probably a good 60 to
80 plus hours potentially even more I
guess you get to argue that Dragon Ball
fighters could do the same you're gonna
go past story mode and maybe instead
comes home all that lab Tom line play
and lab time
oh I tripped way to trip whoo he's like
taking a nap Oh get out of here are you
doing like haha we see a moment hey man
maybe the puke apk has been ruining
their week you're just like all this is
our chance they've never seen him in a
weaker state god I was like maybe I'll
follow through with this combo and see
if I can just barely hit his wing or
something that's kind of like that that
sort of Dark Souls element that you're
talking about too is like you don't want
to spam too much obviously you want to
make sure that if you are hitting a
button that it lands because you know
it's on you if you you press on one too
many times
yeah they're their recovery frames i
frames all the frames you could ever
want in this game you gotta scale he's
gonna fly away go home want to fight you
in your home oh look it's our pal the
great Jagger is he's back later
so you don't wanna have anything to do
with you either all right
there he is
swooping down don't take why should cook
why am I not cooking make some delicious
meat these are the question is the
answer just sit there and wonder all the
time he'll murder it Oh work we're
trying first we want that sweet tail no
no can't believe this I can't believe
you've gone and done this it's fine
but that the fully leveled up sword now
don't run away from me it knows there we
go just bring it down Yahtzee
did we we got the tail something yeah we
did it all that hard work and
perseverance has paid off and now we
have a tailor to cut open can you turn
off scalp eyes is the question being
asked I don't know if you can I haven't
really looked into it they're really
nice though
see they keep the game flowing pretty
pretty well whoa you know he says I just
need my whole tail to slap you I cut it
off I deserve to be hit by it
switch the arrows when it flies up oh
wait I mean technically wait do you have
that slinger thing yet I do okay you
could do that there's shoot rocks at it
how's that rock
let's get distracted just sharpen my
stuff again seems like a good time while
he's in the air
give him a gym a couple of rocks just to
do it
that new longsword movie is beautiful as
the killer look it's so much whoa my god
it's okay he can do it he's really good
at it
apparently power in the kisser Oh
slamma-jamma and bring it back down Oh
like it uh reach blue samake says yes
you can turn off scalp eyes oh there you
go
confirmed Victor her asking what parts
can you cut and break the monsters oh it
depends on the monster but usually it's
like you can cut the tail off you can
break their face if they have like a
like a horn or something you can usually
knock that off you can break their their
feet attacking certain parts of their
body will also like knock them over so
the the one that you saw me fighting
yesterday if I attack its feet it gives
me a good opportunity to put it in one
of its sensitive areas so that's to do
part of the strategy is to dam your roar
yeah right what does it name like the
monster you're fighting we wrap you kqk
it's right under our picture picture the
picture picture of the Pooky Pooky yeah
it's right there see hunt up piqué piqué
and plan that entirely i yeah i measured
it out every single thing in this stream
is 200% calculated we know exactly what
we're doing
yep the puke oh my fav nice got that
tail heck yeah there was like that's
weird
oh that way I just saw him fly the other
way you go to the nest you know the
Flies sometimes they're like a GPS and
they don't know what they're doing you
need to update the firmware or something
man so it's a theory it might be it's
probably because it's flying up to the
tree or something so it's trying to take
me up higher rainbow wizard sort of
but doesn't have that that multicolored
tail do you have to worry about the tail
d spawning uh eventually it will it's
happened to me once okay I was fighting
redacted but uh yeah
oh hello your home jump off that wall I
definitely missed being able to hit him
at this time oh if he had his tail but
exactly if he still had his tail we
would have done it yeah we go that's my
boy
don't mind us get up on his face give
him a good poke yep mm-hmm you're an
idiot you hit your head on the wall stop
hitting yourself
yep mm-hmm
there we go get stabbed so I'm assuming
for you you just do the jolt you do the
the spirit storm which show ah right in
through the eye it's pretty good
I don't know that still doesn't be that
that's which tree which axe man switch
axe is so good so good
that's that destiny fanboy I'll never
take anything serious that comes out of
his mouth yeah that's fair I accept your
proposal suppose I don't know too much
about this game that's why I defer
everything to Ben but I'm looking
forward to playing it though thanks for
sure I will get good as the Internet's
would hearken I'm I'm excited for seeing
how many people in the office like
decide to pick it up I want to see I'll
see how many people are into it I want
to I want to help people get into it be
the Sherpa yeah
well call it a monster on her yeah she
kind of kind of looked over everyone
you're like yeah you got this you can do
it I'll call him senpai I'm into it
looks raged it probably is I mean
getting stabbed and faced that many
times I think I'd be pissed too I'd be
angry yeah cut off my tail
push me around a bit it's it's no good
do some field research on hearing away
they might be running back to their home
possibly I was here earlier this would
have been really good to kind of swing
off of it yeah hit'em bear friend it'll
eventually come out to PC later in the
year but to come to start it's gonna be
on PlayStation 4 as well as the Xbox one
and that'll be tomorrow / Friday
depending on its it's Friday but you're
gonna go too slow they know you're
eating me hungry
bigger I miss see you say peace out okay
let's jump down yeah and then he'll jump
back up to get poison though you want to
got poison not I go no you way to poison
him Oh awesome
it just it left the little trail there
so I thought you might have got him yeah
and as mentioned tomorrow Ben will be
back probably with John Luke they'll be
doing some late rank like ranking the
hunts for high ranking hunts like that
high rank now late game high ranking
fights come watch us get beat up a bunch
by monsters that are even more angry
showcased some of that cool later game
arm where weapons look at that yeah yeah
and we'll be able to talk about a lot
more which is definitely exactly a good
thing - Thank You Thomas Carter hoping
they add variants or D ranks there's
speculation I learned by the gearing
stuff there's a lot of speculation about
GA which I also hope it makes its way in
so how does that work for someone that I
have no idea what that like even means
it's just like extra ranks on top of
your wanna hang out
what he's down with on a tree or a
rocket something in the in the gunk oh
don't go in there no uh why do I it's a
trap Ben you know sometimes you just get
really excited and maybe a little bit
overzealous and you just like fighting
the thing in the actual poison also him
sit in there until he decides a step out
he likes it though yeah that's that's
his natural element sharpening our
butter knife whoo
maybe not so that got him out that's
what we needed
it's all mind games oh he's real tired
oh it's so sick you like it I love it
every time
Oh doing work now right in the face I
can't fly oh you just kind of get more
and more sad as the fight goes you know
just you're like oh man this poor dude
I'm not sad I must you know you did all
that work cuz poison dragon deserves to
die
yeah what does the poison dragon even do
I need your poison dragon parts so I can
make that sweet armor whose poison pants
yeah whoo boy I got like a tennis spread
some butter
no yes dip it in her it's correct you
running away now yeah you are Monday
goon diocese once you get good weapons
you can kill them in like ten minutes
sometimes faster so with my current
character fighting the great jagira sat
like the lower level I was able to
finish him in literally five hits thick
so that was a wonderful experience to
kind of like go back and just do an
investigation hunt just to do it
mistake and mishaps yes PPP the puke a
puke a pants Oh perfect
I'm down with TPP yeah you know me
yeah that's that's the only way to
finish it it's a style the only way to
do it got a style on them pick up that
piercing pod there we go get our carbs
give me that give it to me fight just so
long I don't know if it's fun for you so
it might be kind of like like you're
watching someone do it you're like man
this has been like 15 minutes what is
this it doesn't feel like that while
you're doing it it got more things to
worry about moment to moment cut off
thinking get out of here right here go
home I'm leaving
no why kill his friend
why'd you do this is the only person I
knew in the forest I was gonna sit here
in Rome endlessly forever that's real
sad I'm gonna leave him alone so the
best thing to come up here will be able
to see it they did it kind of in one of
the more recent games too but you get
the last hit screenshot nice so since we
did that really cool like jump off of
him springboard down onto him it'll
probably be a really cool picture I
think I'll be on xbox one it is on Xbox
yes sir it's like a good time here we go
yeah you can hide the menu take a
screenshot to remember it if you want to
just kind of nice almost like we're
shooting a flare in the sky but we're
not shooting a pain its pain it's yes Oh
can't troll my friends anymore
[Music]
the Xbox one version probably will be
until the PC version comes up maybe the
best yeah look that's the one act if you
have a one exit if you have the press
yeah we have the blast element it's my
favorite status tune in tomorrow to find
out yes that could be a no that could be
a maybe who knows if there was someone
who was really into blast elements I
definitely have not been farming up
blast element weapons for a while
alright then as we wind down the stream
is there any is there anything we you
need a showcase before we say goodbye to
our folks until you see them tomorrow I
think I think we've done a pretty good
kind of introductory run nice stuff I
feel pretty good I'm really excited to
beyond tomorrow to talk about more stuff
because I can't talk about yeah this is
the early stuff we were fortunate enough
to be able to preview the game today
yeah this is exactly what we need
everything run around town and show
everyone my cool Pig yeah so yeah thank
you guys all for tuning in and really
appreciate it
it's first hour so maybe a little longer
than that with the character creator
I'll look at that that's the Sun setting
everything's looking real nice and
thanks man for playing of course it
drops into knowledge yeah and everyone
in chat thank you guys for tuning in
don't forget though not only are we
gonna be live again tomorrow with some
later game stuff with Ben and John Luke
in Monster Hunter world but at 2 o'clock
today we're also doing the CF these beta
we're gonna have a crew of four pirates
and they're gonna do some stuff they're
gonna plunder they're gonna get that
booty maybe get drunk
get that booty now drunk is a bad time
it's actually kind of hard to watch I
told them that they probably get too
drunk cuz like you you but there is
going to be drinking and there's gonna
be some Jolly Rogers and all sorts of
crazy cool pirate things yeah so tune
into that that's in about an hour so
please tune into that if not all good
see you some of you folks tomorrow maybe
for the stream tomorrow and Friday we're
not done a Friday we have Dragon Ball
fighters too so for all those people in
the chat that are like I don't know
Dragonball fighters monster underworld
what I do well you can watch that one
shooter make a decision I guess but
until next time and when you see Ben
tomorrow see y'all later bye